[Música]
aquí continuamos continuamente siempre
ha habido
derrame petrolero más que todo en el
tubo viejo fue viejo
el tubo nuevo no no no no tengo
conocimiento que se haya roto pero el
vídeo sí porque tiene una data de más de
60 años de uso
[Música]
y
el paro era político prácticamente y
entonces ya eran dependientes manejaba
su propio recurso y va de acuerdo con la
cuestión de la política y
grava el concepto de derecha de todo mal
yo cuando fuerte al final decadencia
[Música]
no
actualmente sólo un pequeño repunte de
cuatro actividades
cumplimiento parcial de algo parte de
eso se ha deseado como que me dé impulso
cómo podré hacer
de cuatro meses cinco meses atrás
anteriormente eso prácticamente se
estaba parado
[Música]